I want to thank you all what an
incredible moment thirty years of
struggle and sacrifice but it was worth
it
because I finally get to read that ten
words I've longed to hear Raymond Holt
you are not the oops
I misread the email didn't see that not
so I will not be the new commissioner
[Music]
myself dancing did I miss something
feels like I missed something I'm just
gonna keep going until you deserve this
promotion I'm going there and get it
give them hell Greg
[Music]
good morning Carly
Sammy looks like you're keeping the
machines running smoothly whatever Carly
will be the first to go here are your
drinks and a lover's toolbox from a mr.
boy ah thank you so much we will never
open this oh my god cake look yes the
grapes oh and you brought cheese I don't
even watch you know Jake in the lounge
captain Holt hey everyone
just when I introduce you to our new
assistant manager Larry sherbert [ __ ]
all right you want to say a few words
absolutely thanks hey everybody a couple
things about my management style number
one don't nobody ask me about what's in
my cut we hang on had no problems - I
believe in the power of nicknames smile
face senorita swag
and you my friend we will call mr. Park
seems rather unprofessional
he called you mister fired mr. Partin
whoa you really made the balloon arch
made no I'd birthed her there's no form
more graceful than the arch no object
more whimsical than the balloon yes you
and I think that but pole Rosa think
good point Rosa would one a much much
bigger balloon arch back to the balloons
door Peralta bartha's r has a sister
meet Penelope who yeah mom's arm ups
let's not dwell on it we should get back
to work or we could fall asleep for five
to seven days and see how we feel
I will not rest until justice is served
there's no time to waste this case is
urgent hi boy all right listen the case
may not be quite as urgent as once
thought I dug it up out of my desk so
you'd have something to do on weekends
because you seem so lonely you cited
chatter from the streets that Garibaldi
had resurfaced I did I did I did but
said chatter may have been fudged oh you
lied to me not a pity you pity me I
wouldn't put it that way I would I am
offended I am
I am very tired so I'm gonna take a nap
but when I wake up oh you are in for it
how dare you how dare me how dare you I
was just trying to help
well your help feels an awful lot like
pity so do me a favor and don't ever
help me again Wow well you didn't seem
to mind me helping you when I got you
your job I bought a bundle of novelty
shirts at a nearby gift shop
this one says what's up beaches set of
[ __ ] for human reasons but you ain't
humor well I'm a joke now so it suits me
well pimento stares at her Rosa will all
be staring at her yes we will she's
truly breathtaking there's a double
meaning to that the breath that it takes
to inflate all those balloons of course
I used a hand pump but the bum moe
still works Oh No what's happening
someone tell you it's happening I got
some more bad news oh wow that thing's
huge then those are one things to be
classy I mean she's getting married not
finishing a marathon still says the hair
guy stay in your lane bucko right son
Diego the arch sucks I'm sorry I didn't
want to say anything because you're my
boss and you were so excited but the
truth is every time I look at it I want
to die and take you with me
well I wish you'd said something before
I spent all day making it of course you
didn't want to burst my bubble pun
intended and then you did
forget the arch Charles didn't sober up
Rosa she got him drunk Oh No
how drunk is he remember the night they
cancelled Bunheads we're ruined it's
fine I'll handle it you got your hands
full so romantic yeah
and so intimate don't work I'm not
listening to you I'm just thinking about
how this sea bass is cold but not as
cold and cruel as the hands of fate that
have thrust my entire life into darkness
attention squad everyone gather round
I've been researching ways to raise
morale and I found an interesting
article in a scientific journal Oh was
it from the American Journal of no one
cares according to a recent study the
physical act of smiling can improve your
mood
I suggest we give it a shot hmm now your
try big smiles bigger bigger great now
we just have to stay like this for the
next two hours can you feel it working
and that's why you shouldn't drink being
drunk sounds terrible hello Amy I didn't
see you there how did the wedding go
Terry what the hell man you said you're
gonna sober them up Murph all my girls
are never gonna grow up and lose their
virginity
I lost my vCard to the woman that
refilled Nana's oxygen tanks her hands
were so strong from turning the nozzles
this is a room of nightmares you're the
nightmare you made me kill my balloon
baby look at me so drunk I'm a
liberating like a beatnik and what if I
never get a second chance I don't know I
just I'm just sad why I understand
must be very difficult
wait are you crying yes thank you for
acknowledging my feelings thank you for
acknowledging mine we're both great at
this here at the fun zone we live by one
rule when it's your birthday you're
always cool parents and kids are all the
same watch as I do a dance - your name -
Derek Derek you're hot stones on earth
that's for no reason not on mine my
butt's don't keep falling off because
I'm so intense about Hall being here and
ruining everything hasn't been that bad
really
sorry can't even float right just push
me away everyone else goes it's not
great but as long as we staying here
we're safe we're all to San Diego I'm in
your room what how how do door was open
I pushed through the hedge tell me what
is it about me that screams loser yeah
you know we're kinda in the middle of
getting massages right now sir oh how
thoughtless of me
I'll get down here so you can see my
face out uh hello
the question was what is it about me
that screams loser figure out what's
living in there yet well judging by the
empty beer cans the further pornography
in the claw marks I say a homeless man
in a raccoon the exact nature of their
relationship is still revealing itself
I'm gonna assume sexual you're ready to
even those files yet no well then I
guess it's time for your next task
you're gonna need to change
into what Oh mr. fart you look perfect
so some of the costume is that all you
got hardly every time a go-cart drives
by I want you to scream and this is very
important me so corny
you can ruin my job Larry but that's not
all I've got here in Florida I've got a
life I've got friends you sure about
that
honestly Estelle it almost sounds like
you should stop eating beef altogether I
know that's what I keep saying
that's my walking I suppose I can see
how a balloon arch might have been a
little too much oh yeah for sure
no you're supposed to say this wedding
looks like garbage this wedding looks
like garbage no no as long as the Brian
therapy the way the mud revitalizes your
skin and I love how it masks my shame I
am loving this yeah uh I just wanted to
thank you for all your help yesterday I
didn't do much there was nothing good
day what's going on just very busy get
back to work
what are you having there a balloon
large oh my god captain she is
magnificent
[Music]
you